Chris what am a few days have you had
any rest now I can't remember the last
time I've had rest
so you mean your phone must have been
ringing off the hook presumably with
people wanting to protect themselves
well anytime a high-profile attack like
this takes place that is literally
front-page news in every major
publication in almost every major
country cyber security becomes much more
prominent and as it happens we ended up
introducing a brand new technology about
six months ago that was designed
specifically to protect organizations
from precisely this kind of attack so
Ron Simone yes
ransomware it's been it's been a busy
few days right place at the right time
then well yes and this is one of those
things where ransomware has been around
for a while and it's a threat that we've
known about it's continued to grow over
time we have now come out with some
pretty advanced techniques to counter it
but as you saw it's it's it it is the
kind of problem where unless you're
staying on top of it and unless you're
staying current it can have a broad and
and challenging impact for organizations
across the board I mean it was a very
indiscriminate kind of attack it
attacked large organizations small
organizations all over the globe we had
a cybersecurity expert on the show the
night before last and he said we're
going to get more of these being no
doubt is that you're all feeling as well
we will get more of them I mean we see
roughly 400,000 unique pieces of malware
a day coming through our labs and this
is a particularly difficult particularly
challenging attack but it's one of many
and the truth is while this was very
prominent you know we there are
thousands of attacks and data breaches
that take place every single day that
don't ever make it to the front page and
this really ended up serving we think as
kind of a wake-up call to the world of
two things one every organization needs
to make IT security a top priority and
number two it's a real reminder to all
of us
that we've got to get the basics right
some people have said that the people
who are attacked including the NHS which
is one of your clients we should point
out brought this on themselves by having
outdated software is that a fair
accusation I don't think that's fair I
mean the the truth is that it's not as
simple as it sounds to get those basics
right I mean it I should say it's simple
but it's not easy I mean it means making
sure that you're on current operating
systems making sure that those are
patched and kept current making sure
that you have the latest in in IT
security software and solutions from
companies like Sophos and then ensuring
that you keep everything current and
up-to-date that's harder to do than it
sounds when you have obviously in the
case of the NHS it's not a single entity
it's hundreds and hundreds of
organizations they have different
budgets different priorities different
decision making bodies and so trying to
have a single approach is a really tough
call and as you saw 200,000 systems
around the world is probably a low end
of the estimate and it struck everything
everything from very sophisticated large
organisations to very unsophisticated
small organisations Chris Hagen one from
so forth gonna leave it am afraid thanks
for joining me thank you